[Music]
the reaction to two controversial comedy
specials over the Christmas holidays has
shown that the dreaded culture wars are
going nowhere in
2024 the latest Ricky ja special
Armageddon and David Chappelle's the
dreamer have topped the Netflix charts
but also caused a furious backlash from
critics here's a clip from both I've
been doing a lot of video messages
recently for termin Leal children you
know the charity Make A Wish Foundation
they're great and they give these dying
kids they're like one wish and if it's
me I always say yes and I always start
the video the same way I go why didn't
you wish to get
better what you [__] as
well I ain't doing trans jokes no more
you know what I'm going to do tonight
tonight I'm doing your all handicap
jokes well they're not as organized as
the
gays and I love punching
down one critic labeled ja's special
tiresome adolescence offense mongering
while civil rights advocacy group the
national black Justice Coalition called
on Netflix to remove the Chappelle
special from their catalog all together
so should comedy always punch up rather
than down or are comedians free to say
whatever they want even if it offends
joining me now are commentator and
YouTuber Dave rubben comedian James Bar
and here in the studio talk TV
contributor Paula Ron Adrian thank you
all for being with me let me start with
you uh Dave Ruben over in Miami uh do
you think this is a case of sort of
crossing the line or is everything Fair
a game in
comedy well of course everything's fair
game and it's the job of a good comic to
get as close to that line as you
possibly can say something true and then
through humor uh allow people to laugh
at it and when you poke fun at different
groups what you're doing is showing
everybody that that we're all equal
parts of society uh Chappelle and Jes
are two of probably the top 10 comics of
all time but you need only look at a
comedy Legend a guy like Don Rickles who
used to walk up in front of the crowd in
any part of any country and say look at
the black guy the Jew the gay guy the
Italian the WASP the rest of it and what
it did was everybody realized they were
in on the joke that we are a
Multicultural Society and if we can all
poke fun at our silly stereotypes and
everything
then we will actually figure out ways to
build Bridges but everybody these days
seems to want to burn those bridges down
and and make it seem that our skin color
and our religion is the most important
thing about us uh James over there in
Chicago where do you stand on this these
the these two comedians funny or foul
it's so funny that you accidentally
called him David Chappelle just now but
really he's so obsessed with trans
people I think his name should be de cuz
clearly he wants to transition himself I
mean he is absolutely obsessed listen
Dave Chappelle and Rick jaas are both
incredible comedians they have
historically been brilliant afterlife is
great Dave has used his comedy to punch
up by attacking oppression bringing a
light to racism um joking about why he
doesn't call the police so he knows how
to use comedy to point out oppression
and punch up he's holding people
accountable so why now is he punching
down in my opinion I think Dave
Chappelle has cheapened his act Paula
here in the studio Ricky ja said today
he's playing a character when he's on
stage do you agree with that do you buy
it no I don't and I have to say it is
disappointing because for somebody who
is so intelligent so aidite and knows
the power of language The Power of Words
to have become so basic and simplistic
in his comedy is is disappointing um and
it is basic and simplistic and if you're
talking about Building Bridges if you're
talking about bringing communities
together how is it that you are
basically poking your
finger at one particular community and
when you talk about um you know making
fun of of sick children of of dying
children I just wonder how desperate you
have to be to do that and and you know
we've we we've got a um there's been a a
poll now uh um that's just been uh
commenced I think uh by a mother whose
son sadly had cancer but I I think is
now better and so 13 and a half thousand
people who have signed up to her poll um
to hopefully get that joke removed from
net Netflix and I can understand why
she's doing that um Dave Rubin you know
it raises this question of whether there
are or should be I know about oh God are
there any taboos in comedy I mean I
thought I thought when watching suddenly
the the the Ricky jaes one I did think
slightly you know it kind of felt a bit
like gosh you're choosing really loow
hanging fruit to sort of hit against
here you know I mean but it seems
because this is the most popular show on
both these shows are the most popular
shows on Netflix there's clearly a huge
audience for it uh whether people find
it funny or offensive or not well look
the audience in that room found it funny
and those are the people who were buying
tickets to Ricky J so we can all Whittle
down whether we think that specific joke
you know I don't think he was making fun
of the sick kids per se he was making
sort fun of the absurdity that someone
like him would be on a make AWI list
that's what the joke really was about
his I don't think and I don't think
anyone on this panel thinks honestly
that Ricky deras has some grudge against
sick kids at all and as for Chappelle
talking about trans people first off uh
you know if if we're going to do this
based on oppression who you're allowed
to talk about based on perceived
oppression are we only allowed to make
jokes about straight white Christians
who are wealthy is that is that what
comedy really is I don't think so and I
don't think anyone else really thinks so
either comedy again is the great
equalizer so if you're just going to
decide okay we can make fun of these
people but not fun of these people
people you're going to have an awful lot
of angry people at the end of the day oh
you know I would accept that I I would
wholeheartedly accept that cuz no I
don't believe Ricky chave thinks that
sick children are a cheap joke and I
don't think actually that Dave Chappelle
and we've seen him on Instagram
attempting to pull back from the
comments that he's made so you know I
fully accept that and that's why I'm
saying first of all it's a cheap shot
and when Dave Chapel is quoted as saying
that you know uh comedians have have um
it's their duty to be Reckless
this is where I disagree and this is
where we need to look at responsibility
it's not a comedian's job actually to be
Reckless it's a comedian's job to be
funny and if they're going to do
politics if they're going to do about
marginalized groups then come on be
intelligent about it make us think don't
do cheap School playground Antics James
uh you know all of Comedy James doesn't
it sort of it's all about transgression
to some extent comedians do have a
larger bandwidth than other people in
society to say edgy thing things uh but
do you think where are the boundaries in
your view listen I think it is a form of
activism and I do agree with both Paula
and Dave here like it is such a Nuance
conversation but really it is at its
best when it's a weapon against the
powerful and Ricky ja laughing at
disabled kids it's just it's a waste of
of bandwidth it's a waste of an
opportunity to say something important
and he says he's a free speech activist
but he has a joke about the n-word and
he doesn't say the nword so either are a
free speech activist or you're being a
[__] like which is it well that's very
interesting I I mentioned earlier
producers you know some people use
saying in pieces about the J special
they're saying the r word and I said
look I mean we've already got the NW and
everyone does know what that means but
if you then got the r word that you're
not meant to say as well we're going to
get a whole alphabet of a word b word c
words that aren't meant to be said Dave
rubben are there any words you wouldn't
say um well in that you're the guest
host of today's show Jo and maybe you
want to return I'm not going to say them
right now uh but look within context
within context could you are there could
you say the n-word within a certain
context and say it not to be racist of
course you could if you were discusting
discussing historical reasons why people
said it or if you were making fun of
people that use language like that uh
but this this constant push for any time
of comedian if we're all basically I
think we're all agreeing here that these
guys are pretty damn funny so maybe
there's a little lwh hang fruit here or
there or maybe one joke misses that is
the challenge of a great comic that you
are going to spend an awful lot of time
in a bunch of really crappy clubs night
after night perfecting that hour set so
that you can get it on Netflix and it is
possible that one joke may fall flat and
that is the risk that you are going to
have to take Douglas I'll text you some
of those words I just don't want to put
it on television I don't I don't want I
don't the text of those words I don't
incriminate in your Foul Play Reuben
look I mean what's interesting by the
way about this was that that that Ricky
jaes as James says doesn't say the NW he
refers to the n-word but the Chappelle
special has almost nothing but the
n-word in it I mean I was sort of a
little bit bruised by just hearing it
constantly I I admire I think Chappelle
is the greatest comic on the planet but
it is a little bit sort of wearing wow I
don't I don't know about greatest comic
on this planet I accept that he has done
amazing things and made amazing strides
in terms of Comedy um for people of
color uh you being uncomfortable about
him using the nword I'm uncomfortable
about lots of people who use the n-word
um there is a context I agree um it's a
poetic context it's an artistic uh
context do I think that Dave Chappelle
is an artist no I don't um and
especially when he says as I said to be
Reckless is his duty that's
disappointing well Paula in the studio
and comedians Dave and James over there
in America thank you all for joining us
tonight I texted you Douglas I texted
you not opening that one I think Douglas
knows the word no no I'm not opening
that
text